je pense que c'était indispensable de
pousser ce cri d' alerte lui c'est
nicholas cros qui un journaliste
scientifique et son cri d' alerte et
terriblement actuelle près de 60 ans
plus tard l'homme du xxème siècle
considère la planète terre comme sa
propriété exclusive en 1962 il produit
une émission consacrée aux conséquences
des actions de l'homme sur la nature
l'homme de 1962 particulièrement
inconscient un message qui ne raisonnent
pas vraiment en 1962 alors que la
société de consommation est à son apogée
pourtant le journaliste est formel il
faut s'aligner cette activité est
absolument exubérante extraordinaire de
l'homme dans nos temps modernes avec le
développement des industries avec le
développement exponentiel de cette
activité humaine la pullulation humaines
qui font que les conditions de vie se
modifie et qu'il faut prendre un certain
nombre de décisions pour que cette vie
humaine puisse se continuer et déjà à
l'époque les scientifiques ont bien
diagnostiquer les causes précises de
cette course à la catastrophe
déforestation pollution agriculture
appauvrissant les soldes braconnage les
animaux aussi sont sa propriété
il que les abattre comme le désire il ne
s'en prive pas d'ailleurs pendant 40
minutes des phrases chocs et
malheureusement prophétique
la terre n'est pas comme nous l'avons
cru longtemps un territoire infinie doux
et de richesses d'illimité que nous
pouvons gâcher ou détruire à notre aise
au contraire c'est un patrimoine que
nous devons conserver qui est un autre
mesure à notre dimension parmi les
personnes interviewées louis armand haut
fonctionnaire avait peut être la
solution
nous pensons impossible la population en
général et pépin formé de tri danger y
aurait une prise de conscience de la
population et qui orient près les
techniciens vers des solutions plus
humaines
mais la prise de conscience arrive un
peu tard selon l'onu près d'un million
d'espèces seraient menacées d'extinction
dans les prochaines décennies
[Musique]